wie schon bekomme ich hier auch das
dings zugeworfen und kriege den respekt
und ich werde auch jetzt hier wie dort
von blog seid doch alle ihr seid der
super toll ihr motto was
hallo mein name ist luca und ich zeige
euch heute mal wieder drei coole com ans
werk
das allererste was wir eingeben des sfb
command unterstrichen blog damit wir
einen command block erhalten und dazu um
diesen command blogs aktivieren brauchen
wir wie immer noch einen hebel den
können wir jetzt ganz simpel hier
einfach hinsetzen und den hebel hin und
dann ich sollte eventuell erst mal den
kommen eben kopiert den kopierten
command fügen wir jetzt hier eindrücken
auf fertig und betätigen den hebel und
da sage ich schon mal der zeit wo das
ganze eben stellen geschaffen
es ist schon fertig geschaffen das ging
sehr sehr schnell dieser command ist von
scott ashley scott scott das glaube ich
dass es so ausgesprochen wird und zwar
müssen wir bei diesem command wieder ein
wenig selber aktiv werden und zwar an
der suche ein x blades angeben und uns
ein place rott nehmen und auch einmal
ein beziehungsweise nein geben so dass
wir einen eisenbahnen bekommen wenn wir
jetzt nämlich die lohnen route und den
eisenbahnen da hinschmeißen bekommen wir
ein laser sport und spaß das ganze der
laserschwert dieses laserschwert ist
jetzt noch nicht aktiviert da sehen wir
dass ein sondern gleich - gleich -
gleich das steht für nicht deag tag an
nicht aktiviert also deaktiviert und ihr
seht doch das ganze ding leuchtet nicht
allerdings wenn ich jetzt hinschmeißen
wieder aufs aber seht ihr schon das
ganze schimmert wie sonstwas und da
stehen immer noch diese drei komischen
sachen allerdings steht daran jetzt auch
schärfe fünf das heißt wir haben dieses
dieses ganz normale frau damit jetzt
quasi durch das hinwerfen
wie cool sieht dass da hinten eigentlich
aus alter theorie aber ich bin immer so
ein sonst sieht hunter und da hinten ist
auch noch direkt zum dorf alter sagt
alle die den sie wollen hier ist lösch
sieht und der sieht geht einfach direkt
unter diesen ganzen komische sorry dass
ich euch jetzt nicht geben konnte weiß
nich hättet ihr lust mal auf seine
siegserie dass ich euch mal so 2 3 1
oder so vorstelle in sowas wie die
command seriös ein bisschen nicht
vielleicht habt ihr habt ihr lust habt
den einnahmen keine okay dann ja wir
machen weiter mit dem command die welt
sieht sehr schön aus aber egal
jedenfalls dieses laserschwert hat ihr
cher fünf und damit wenn ich damit jetzt
mops angreifen sind ja dementsprechend
sehr schnell tot das heißt wenn ich mir
beispielsweise hier mal eine ich habe
auch genau wie das schaf ein gegeben
weil in jedem scheiß dinge verschafft
drin steht
aber jetzt habe ich hier beispielsweise
ein schaf kann jetzt mal hier ein paar
scharfe gesetze und ihr seht schon wenn
das laserschwert jetzt gerade aktiviert
ist
draufschlagen die teile sind einfach
direkt tot wenn ich das ganze ding dann
allerdings wieder hinschmeißen das ganze
zeit ist deaktiviert
muss ich hier ja auch jeder schafft war
schon vorher angedeutet allerdings wenn
ich ihr normalen schaffen setzte seht
ihr dann 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 und wenn ich
das ganze aktiviere machnig ein schaf
mit 12 schlägen kaputt also das ist so
eine art laserschwert das ist quasi
einfach nur schrott ein bisschen
schimmert und schärfe 5 hat ich weiß
nicht was da unten soll das das da die
ganze zeit sich die daten verändern ich
glaube es gibt zu denken wie command
outlook falls teilst du da irgendwie so
aber schreibt mir mal bitte noch mal die
kommentare damit ich genau weiß wenn sie
etwas das nächste mal passiert dass der
ganze chat zugesperrt wird dass ich dann
weiß welchen chromatisch eingeben muss
und das wieder rückgängig zu machen
der nächste command wurde mir zugesagt
von thq mahnt blogs oder thc oder das
glaube ich eher weniger ich füge diesen
command hier ein und drücke den schalter
und zwar ist der bären kommt ihr seht
schon hier wenn hier steht stark
maschinen kann nicht einfach auf start
maschinen drücken und wenn ich mir jetzt
einen zombie spawn einnehme und einen n
will bzw einen amboss und deutsch
übersetzt und jetzt gehe ich in den
amboss rein und benennen das zombie
spawn einfach auf wer also bioware das
ist ja eigentlich schon heißt es oh okay
hier steht der heißt aushalten ausstehen
allerdings als nomen heißt bier oder der
bbl wird das ausgesprochen können wir
das eventuell diese kluge app hier
zeigen es heißt sprache okay wir haben
wir was ist genau das item habe ich
jetzt eben inventar und wenn ich das
hier einfach mal hinsetzen seht ihr
schon sport ein ganz normaler zombie
allerdings danach verwandelt er sich
direkt in diesen bären und das hier soll
irgendwie das gesicht von behren
darstellen und den kann ich auf schlaf
jetzt gehe ich grad natürlich wieder
eine mail sorry dass die folgen wieder
total kaputt ich kann den bären hier
schlagen und
also das ist schwer ihn zu treffen ihr
seht schon ich glaub ich um den rum und
immer wenn ich schlage ihnen die einmal
von den ganzen malen
ich treffe ihn irgendwie gerade
überhaupt nicht doch da hinten da ich
muss ihn von hinten auf dem possen dem
dem geilen typen jedem garten hängen es
okay will jetzt eventuell auch noch mal
sterben also wären greifen euch auch an
und ihr könnt auch wären angreifen und
eigentlich gruppen die auch noch ein
während fleisch allerdings war das beim
jetzt gar nicht der fall ich greife den
hier mal eben noch an und schaut der mir
da genau da haben wir es und das ist ein
bmi und virgin ich kann das essen das
wird jetzt bei hunger balken von mir auf
und das ist quasi einfach so kakaobohnen
allerdings heißen die bären fleisch und
ich kann ja direkt essen
aber es sind halt quasi einfach locker
kakaobohnen also ein ganz simpler kommen
noch nie als zweiter command weil viele
bilder bemängelt hatte dass diese serie
noch aus so mega komplexen commands
bestellt deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
ich nehme heute drei sind dokument und
wir kommen jetzt schon zum dritten
command der dritte command ist diesmal
gar kein roman sondern ich bin dafür
gerade extra eine andere welt gegangen
und zwar ist dieser coup
diese welt von minecraft findet
natürlich den download von der welt
diesmal auch in der beschreibung und
zwar ist des flame frauen bzw
flammenwerfer command welt dingsbums
exporte hier gerade mal eben mehrere
mops damit ihr seht wie das ganze
funktioniert und zwar mich jetzt so von
fünf verschiedenen sorten sonntags
gespannt und zwar habe ich einmal dieses
flame frau item das ist einfach ein
schneeball den ich auf mops werfen kann
und die hat schon gesehen wenn ich damit
den ochtruper wehr viertel explodieren
halt die krise also ich kann noch mal
eben so und clipper hinstellen es ist so
wie wenn ich konnte nicht werfen flames
auf ihn drauf und der explodierte sie
wenn ich den auf anderen mops frau wäre
für seht ihr schon verbrennen die recht
schnell also die machen sehr sehr
krassen schaden als ich in letzter zeit
ist einfach mal hier so ein paar
schneeball rein und ihr seht schon alle
sind einfach direkt verbrannt und das
gleiche gibt es auch als station larry
flynt froh das heißt da wo ich hin
schauen den hinsetze verfügt dieses ding
hier quasi macht das feuer hinter ihr
seht schon das schaf ist auch relativ
schnell tot und dieses ding greift mich
jetzt auch als spieler an das heißt wenn
ich in den games null gehe und mich
herein stelle seht ihr schon bekomme ich
hier auch bis links zugeworfen und
pflege den usa wächst und ich werde auch
jetzt schon lange seid doch alle ihr
seid ja super toll ihrem artikel auch
etwas
wenn ich allerdings diesen schneeball
mit dem claim frau auf mich drauf
schmeißen würde würd ich halt keinen
schaden bekommt sieht nicht daran dass
ich hart im game und 1 bin sondern wenn
ihr das auch andere spieler wirft
passiert nix allerdings bei diesem dings
wenn ich dadurch laufe im game nur
passiert schon was um mit dem mops
passiert immer was und wie kann man mit
diesen sachen relativ schnell töten also
auch ein sehr simpler dritter command
jeder command heute sehr simpel und
nicht so umfangreich wie hier o'brien
boss battle oder in ein riesiges hotel
erschaffen oder was weiß ich wer ganz
simple coole alte oldschool folge denn
ihr coole commands kennt dann schreibt
sie in die beschreibung wenn es euch
gefallen da würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freunden zeigt die serie euren
freunden oder familie eurer mutter und
oma einer tochter und ich mach jetzt ein
schnitzel weil ich hab jetzt hunger und
hallo zombie